I always have his back Jersey Shore's
Vinny on castmate Ronnie ortiz-magro
following Ronnie's recent baby mama
drama I honestly I haven't spoken to him
I can't comment for everything I see
news like you guys see news I wish him
the best I hope he works it out
according to multiple reports
Ronnie filed a battery domestic violence
report against his on-again off-again
girlfriend Jen Harley after the Las
Vegas metropolitan Police Department
confirmed that he is a person of
interest involving an alleged break-in
at Jen's home this is just the latest
drama to unfold between the couple who
share a nine month old daughter
ariana together in October he took to
his Instagram story to share this photo
of himself sporting a black eye which he
implied he got from Jen last June Jen
was arrested on one count of misdemeanor
domestic battery after allegedly
dragging Ronnie with a car Vinny also
gave et updates on his other co-stars
including new mom Deena Deena is doing
amazing you know we were all in a group
chat together so she was keeping us
up-to-date with everything and you know
so we're all obviously everyone going
through there's so much to talk about
you know what I mean but uh we all we
all do keep in touch we had the the
preliminary baby gifts that we sent but
I know that like that changes a lot I'm
like not the right person to ask about
baby stuff but I'll be there to support
uncle Vinny will babysit whenever I can
mom of three to be Snooki she's good you
know she's like a pro at this now it's
our third time around so I think she'll
be okay and Mike the situation
Sorrentino who married his longtime love
Lauren in October and the coolest part
is that it's gonna be on this show so
you know you guys will see the actual
like you know not just like a quick
little flash of it every step of the
process that we went through with him
we'll be on the show the most important
part that the bride and the groom
actually like each other but then
everything else that was also like
over-the-top and Italian and beautiful
Mike will report for a eight month long
prison sentence On January 15th in 2018
the reality star pleaded guilty to one
count of tax evasion
Mike's co-stars were by his side during
his October sentencing with Jersey Shore
cameras rolling Mike's court stuff like
you're gonna see a lot of that which I
think it's part of that season and then
going forward we don't know where we're
gonna go I just show up you know and
then I don't I don't know what then it
becomes TV somehow
[Music]